decision tree in our welcome to decision
tree in our by simply learned my name is
Richard Kirchner with the simply learned
team that's WW simply learned calm get
certified
get a hit and we'll be doing part 1 in a
two-part series decision tree followed
by random forest because the decision
tree is part of the random forest what's
in it for you first we'll cover what is
a decision tree what problems can be
solved using decision trees how does the
decision tree work and then we'll dive
into a use case survival prediction in
our so I'll be using the our platform on
this one
so what is a decision tree and here we
have kind of a new looking front panel
of a car driving down the street and we
have left or right so you're coming to
an intersection you get assigned which
way to go you're gonna go left or you're
gonna go right wait or go so do you go
right away we have a green light
so probably want to go right away after
you check for cross traffic make sure no
one is asleep at the will or talking on
their cell phone decision tree is a tree
shaped algorithm used to determine a
course of action each branch of the tree
represents a possible decision
occurrence or reaction so another
examples we have a shopkeeper very
nondescript shopkeeper kind of old
spooky without the eyes so we have a
shopkeeper and you must organize his
stall so I must organize my stall and
just looking around trying to figure out
what the best way to stack all his goods
are and he has some broccoli some
oranges and some carrots this is kind of
a nice example because we can see where
some of the colors and shapes overlap or
others don't and so you can create a
tree out of this very easy to say is it
colored orange if it's not what goes
into one stack well that happens to be
all their broccoli and if it is colored
orange then it goes into another stack
and you're like well that's still kind
of chaotic you know people are looking
at carrots and orange has a very strange
combination to put in a box so the next
question might be is it round and if it
is then yes you put the oranges into one
box and no that means it's carrots we
put it in the other box and you can see
that a lot of stuff we do in life
usually can fall into like a decision
tree how do you decide something you
know does it go left does it go right
yes or no and even with this we even
have a number of
and choices broccoli carrots and oranges
so what kind of problems does it solve
what problems can be solved by using a
decision tree classification we're
dealing with the classification
identifying to which set an object
belongs and from our example we just
looked at a carrot is orange while
broccoli is green
I guess it's nondescript days without
the faces I love it because a lot of
says you're looking at data you really
don't want to know what exactly the data
is but you're sorting it so you know
like this kind of represents data that
you really don't know exactly where it's
coming from just kind of a fun thing
regression regression is another problem
the biggest can be solved regression
problems have continuous or numerical
valued output variables example
predicting the profits of a company so
we have two different primary problems
we solve for we solve for classification
is it green or is it orange and we solve
for regression which is a continual
number so you know if you're doing
stocks this would be a dollar value that
ranges anywhere from zero to thousands
of dollars how does a decision tree work
terms you must know first so before we
dive into the decision tree let's look
at some of the terminology for the
decision tree we have notes each
internal node in a decision tree is a
test which splits the objects into
different categories and continuing with
our vegetable stand example we have
broccoli no it's not orange and oranges
and carrots are and so on so you can see
right there where it splits that's a
note where the oranges split in the
carrot split into two each of their own
groups and each one of the splits is a
node the very top node of the decision
tree is called the root node so the very
first one we started off where we split
it is a colored orange and you can see
that pointed out nice and neatly there
this is a root node at the top each
external node in a decision tree is
called the leaf node the leaf node is
the output and you can see down here we
have our broccoli and we have our
carrots and our oranges each one of
those is a leaf node so to quickly
rehash our terms we have any where there
is a split
that's a node and if it's at the very
top of the tree that's the root node and
if you're at the very bottom of the tree
where you have a final answer
as the leaf node so you have a root node
a leaf node and then everything else is
just a generic node so one of the most
important terms or concepts that powers
a decision tree is entropy entropy is a
measure of the messiness of your data
collection the Messier or more random
your data higher will be the entropy so
we can see here we have broccoli oranges
and carrots are all mixed together and
it's very chaotic and you could say this
collection has high entropy and if we
sort out the carrots out of here within
I guess just one of the broccoli I don't
know where the other broccoli went you
could save it if you have just the
oranges and the broccoli this is a lower
entropy
they say this collection has low entropy
but really it's higher and lower one is
higher lower than the other one
and from entropy we get information gain
information is the decrease obtained and
entropy by splitting the data set you
based on some conditioning so we have
our information one which we can
actually there's actual computations and
so we have our e one which is put in
there for our entropy value at the base
node a root node and we have two a two
which is a leaf node and so we can
actually calculate those calculations
for entropy and we actually look at
those two values the entropy and we take
that we have e 1 is greater than e 2
therefore the information gain equals e
1 minus e 2 so here we have another
example and we're actually going to
attach some values to this one in just a
moment so we're gonna move away from the
fruit and we're gonna go to everybody's
favorite thing organizing a child's
closet and here we have a young lady
waving at us
hi my cupboard is a mess I must organize
my stuff and we're gonna classify the
objects based on their attribute set
using a decision tree we can look at it
we have a shape a size and a label and a
number and I'm gonna go ahead and look
at the labels because that's really
what's key on this one is we have a
couple balls in here some books cards
and blocks and if you look at that when
you have something that's a ball it's
round so it's a very different shape the
book card and blocks are all rectangular
but the books are a different size so
the books have like a size six I guess a
you think of them as very large cards
as for so they're not quite as big and
the blocks or little Lego blocks that
looks like kind of fun to stack on there
and then we can actually quantify this
we can actually say hey we got we have
different numbers we have two balls two
books one card four blocks and we split
at each level based on certain
conditions on the attributes so
splitting aims at reducing the entropy
and we have a formula our first and
actual formula you'll see happens in the
background when we're running these
different modules in our it looks a
little complicated but we can break that
up and simplify that for you so we see
this formula the negative sum of I of X
equals the probability of one value of x
times the log of two probability value
of x the term probability value of X
it's probably easiest to understand if
we go ahead and put the numbers in there
so you can actually see what we're
looking at and so we plug the numbers in
there we look at the probability of the
value of x well if we do the number of
balls there's two balls and the total
number of items is nine so we have a
probability of any one object being two
out of nine so that's pretty
straightforward math when you look at
the numbers you can actually see that
very easily and so we can calculate our
entropy of two over nine times the
squared log of 2 over nine plus 1/9 the
log squared of 1 over nine plus four
over nine times a log square root of 4
over 9 so our whole group is the sum of
all the entropies and so when we look at
that we have the entropy of the balls
which is the two over nine rectangles
two over nine or mean books two over
nine cards one over nine and the blocks
for overnight and we can just plug those
numbers in there and we get an actual
value of one point eight two eight two
so what the heck does a module do with
that number well now we must find the
conditions for our split every spit must
give us the maximum achievable
information gain and so we have our
first entropy value one point eight two
eight two and it turns out when you
compare all the different individual
entropy values for the balls for the
books for the cards for the blocks
rectangles you find out that the biggest
split is going to be in the shape and
it's going to be our first split we'll
be on the show
it will directly segregate the balls out
so they'll split up a huge group from
one from the other and so we compute
that we end up with e 2 which is all of
our rectangles and then we have a leaf
node which is the balls and so with our
e 2 we see that 1.3 7 8 4 is much less
than the 1 point 8 2 8 2 and so our
second split will be on the size is that
will directly segregate the books and so
how we do that we can see that if it
size is greater than 5 all the books go
to one side while the cards and the
blocks go to the other and again we have
our III which equals 0.716 which is
considerably less than one point 374 so
our entropy is dropping each time we do
a split and of course our third split we
look at and we'll see that we're left
with size again and we've split it with
4 and 2 in this case if it's greater
than 3 it's going to be a block if it's
less than 3 is going to be a card and at
this point each of our objects is looped
into similarity so they all look the
same and we end up with an entropy of 0
and so you can see as we go down the
entropy continues to get less and
because it hits zero we can say all our
objects are now classified with a
hundred percent accuracy if it was only
that easy to clean the kids closets and
you can see we have a nice drawing that
shows you where all the leaf nodes are
on this in which case we have the balls
the books the blocks and the cars are
part of the leaf node and the root node
is our first split we have all the
object and we're splitting them by
rectangle by shape so we're going to
dive in to the use case and in this case
we're gonna get a little morbid there I
am behind my desk that's definitely not
me I don't have that big of a chin but I
do usually have a cup of coffee now
let's kind of like that it's sitting
next to me on my desk so the use case
this is going to be a survival
prediction in our and let's implement a
classification of data set based on
information gain this is gonna use the
id3 algorithm don't let that scare you
that's the most common algorithm they
used to calculate the decision tree
there's a couple different ways they can
calculate the entropy but the formula is
all the same behind it so int 3 is most
common in R and then we'll be using the
R studio for our interface for our IDE
so our studio is free to download
there's the free version of course
enterprise version and there's all kinds
of different choices in there but one of
the wonderful things about our is that
it's been an open source for a very long
time and it's very well developed it's
also very quick and easy to use on a lot
of things so this is gonna be in the our
studio IDE
there's some other interfaces but this
is I would suggest using the our studio
it's the most common one and if you
remember I said this is gonna be a
little morbid because we're talking
about how many people survived and died
on these ships so in this case we have a
nice vacation cruise ship going on there
or I'm not sure what that is with the
tugboat so we have a ship and it had 20
lifeboats the lifeboats were distributed
based on the class gender and age of the
passengers we will develop a model that
recognizes the relationship between
these factors and predicts the survival
of a passenger accordingly so we want to
predict whether the person is going to
survive or die in a shipwreck and we'll
be using a data set which specifies if a
passenger on a ship survived its wreck
or not so we're gonna look at this data
and if you open it up into a spreadsheet
and don't forget you can always put a
note on the YouTube video down below and
we will be monitoring that you can
request the data set sent to you or more
correspondence you can also go to WWE
learn comm and request this data set -
it's just a simple CSV file we'll send
out and you can see right here we have
survived so one indicates a person
survived the wreck zero they didn't make
it
they were under the water and the luxury
class of the cabin so if they were in
you know what would value is like one
two three depending on what luxury class
they were and then we have this is kind
of interesting how many siblings they
had it's just kind of an interesting
added statistic in their number of
parents on board and disembark location
so where the destination is so here
we've opened up our studio and if this
is your first time in our studio you'll
notice that it opens up standardly in
three panes the upper left is for text
documents are bringing in and then the
bottom left is the actual commands as
they're processed and then on the
right-hand side you have your
environment setup on there now I've
zoomed in with my font little oversized
fact we can even take that up one more
size and see if we get a
your setup view here we go so I've set
the font for 18 probably a lot larger
than you need to work on a project and
the first thing I'm going to do is on
the right-hand panel we're gonna be
working with plots so I'm going to click
on the little plot tab up there and I'm
just going to collapse that over to the
side for right now and then I'm gonna
open up the bottom one and you'll see on
the top I actually have two different
tabs team in the back was really nice to
set up the whole package for what we're
working on here and we'll go through
this line by line and then you'll see as
we execute the different lines they're
gonna appear down below so I'll be
flipping between these two left panels
and let me go backwards just for a
second here we're gonna do this part so
let's take a look at the installs and if
you look at the installs and when I'm
not gonna actually run the install scuzz
I already run them on my computer so
these are already installed in my our
packages and I don't have to rerun them
we have a number of packages we're
bringing into our because that's how our
functions and the first number of
packages are all part of our decision
tree so our F selector our our part our
carrot with the dependencies equal true
and our DP Lyr and our part plot that's
a mouthful you'll need to import all of
these in your setup and the first one
which is your F selector compute your
tri squared your information gained your
entropy all of those formulas are part
of the F selector so when you bring it
in that's what that package is the R
part is your partitioning of your
decision tree so these are your primary
two decision tree modules that we're
bringing in the carrot is apart for
actually splitting apart the data
because we always want to do a test set
a train set so they built a package
carrot to kind of handle all those
you'll see carrot used a lot of other
machine learning packages when you're
doing the are the DP Lyr is for mutating
your data so you can sum it and classify
it you can filter it that's all part of
the DPL yr and then our part has another
piece called plot and that's where
helping us plot the data as we sort out
the tree because the art part creates
the tree but you still want to be able
to plot it and then we come down here
and we have some of
additional tools we're gonna work with a
spreadsheet this is a Microsoft Access
spreadsheet so we're gonna use the xlsx
package to import it and you might think
that's a little outdated because I know
when I'm doing any new projects I try to
save my data into a comma separated
variable file or something more
standardized but a lot of times you'll
end up with these old databases where
they're exporting data and their export
comes in an Excel spreadsheet and guess
what this is a time-saver instead of
opening up the spreadsheet receiving it
as a comma separated variable file you
can just open it right up in R which is
really nice and then we have our data
tree which goes right along with
displaying the data so we have our R
part plot and we're gonna put that into
the data trees have a nice visual and
finally you need to install the package
CA tools and CA tools is another package
used for general manipulation of your
data and your vectors so it also has a
split function for training data I know
we have another package for that but
both those packages fit in there as far
as the working with the data so a lot of
times you'll see these loaded in there
together and you'll see in a moment
we'll import the elementary stat learn
package also which is very generic
working with data set up as far as
statistics and data processing now
because my java setup is a little
different because I used a developer
package well the latest update of the
developer package and the R are
struggling to see each other so I need
to go ahead and add this in chances are
you don't need to worry about this but
if you do get an hour job an error
you'll need to go ahead and add an align
to set your environment I'm just gonna
set the Java home I went ahead and
looked up the last solid JRE folder
you'll see under Program Files Java you
can look them all up to make sure it's
the JRE and not the JDK the difference
between those is one is a standard
executable that's a JRE folder and it is
a folder in an actual file and the JDK
deals more with developer site on things
and I'm gonna go ahead and run this and
if you're in AR you can run these lines
individually by holding your ctrl key
down and hitting the enter button so
I've now loaded my workspace and set my
environment here and we can actually
look and just make sure a system dot get
environment is the
to sit one and I can just look real
quick and say hey what's my java home
set to and if I run that whoops I forgot
to put brackets around it there we go if
I do that you'll see that it's set to
the JDK one 802 five and again we're
looking at the split screen and let me
just move this up here a little bit and
let me hit the enter key a bunch time so
it comes up on the screen when I run it
and I'm running it line by line the run
text that appears down here this is
what's actually being executed so I
could just as easily type it in down
here as putting it up here on the top
part place just a little bit of our
studio and working with our studio so
I've shown you the installs and again
I've already installed it on my computer
so it takes a minute or two to install
it we need to go ahead and then bring
those libraries in to work with so
basically we're going through all the
different libraries we're using elements
that learn as a standard our library so
it should already be installed you don't
have to install that one and I can just
go right down them and you'll see as I
install them that they show up on the
bottom and every time you go to run a
new setup you need to go ahead and
install these pull the libraries in you
get till the till you're our or studio
these are the libraries you're using
and you can see right down here that as
it executes them it has all the
different things one of them had like a
couple different parts to it so loaded
the lattice and the ggplot2
really nothing to worry too much unless
you see errors down here so if you start
getting error codes then you might have
to go troubleshoot and find out why it's
not installing correctly or did it
install correctly but it's pretty
straightforward we've covered all the
libraries
and again if you want a copy of this
code simply Ladin a comment down below
on the YouTube video or visit
www.mptv.org/outdoorwisconsin
the next step is we want to go ahead and
load the excel file after setting the
working directory
so let's go ahead and set the working
directory SC WWD is command for that in
our and then this is wherever you have
downloaded your data to in your files to
a lot of times if you get the zipped
framework sent to you it will unzip all
into one location and then you can look
that location up and put that in here a
lot of times it automatically sets that
for you if you all if you're working in
the same directory in this case you can
see I've pasted it in very lengthy path
because I have this as part of my
documents and my business Docs and
simply learn in marketing videos and so
on what I'll go ahead and do the control
enter and run that so now my working
directory is set and you can see down
below it's executed this on the console
down here and if I open up that working
directory you can see I have a ship XLS
file that's the data we're gonna look at
and we looked at that on the slide you
could also open this up and I want to go
ahead and open it up with a notepad by
default it will open up as a spreadsheet
hope it is an excel file so I'd have to
open it up as an actual spreadsheet
wasn't thinking that one through this is
one of the problems with saving stuff as
a proprietary ship saw file even as
something as widely used as Microsoft
Excel spreadsheet but when we open up
the spreadsheet you can see here the
same data we looked at before this was
coming up in this file and so I take
this file we can go ahead and that some
create a variable we'll call it add and
we're going to assign it
that's what the lesser then - means if
you've never used our before we're just
gonna sign it ship Excel asks and then
I'll do my control enter and you'll see
it run down here ship add as a sign ship
dot XLS our Excel spreadsheet on there
and then let's have another variable
we'll call it DF for data frame and
we're going to assign this read X LS x
and that's from the library SL xx that
we just import it and we want to read
the file add because we just created
that variable with the ship XLS and I
didn't catch this right away but you'll
see when we open it up in a spreadsheet
it might be hard to see in your video
screen it has the first sheet is called
ship one so this data is on the page
ship one in the excel spreadsheet and we
got to make sure that we tell the reader
to look for that and so we can simply do
that in our command line sheet name
equals and it was ship one on there so
we go ahead and hit the control enter
and run this line and it brings it down
below and executes it it's now reading
in that data from that spreadsheet
that's what's going on and takes it just
a moment to go ahead and read it in
and then with any data processing we
need to select the meaningful columns
for the prediction so this is important
that we sort through our data and set it
correctly so that whatever we're feeding
it into can read it quick
we can do this with D F we're going to
reassign it and we're going to select
and from there we're going to select D F
as our main data frame going in and then
list the columns that we want
and if we look at the data we have
survived we have a class we have a name
sex and age and then there's siblings
and parents we really don't want to know
the name because we don't need the name
to run this on here and then we got
aside which one of these we want to work
with and the guys in the back played
with the data a little bit and they came
up with the following columns survived
which we need definitely because that's
what we're actually trying to figure out
was whether we're gonna survive or not
what class they're which class of the
boat they're writing in or their first
class second class sex and age we went
ahead and drop the rest of them or at
least for this example and so I can go
ahead and do my control-enter and you'll
see it execute down below and now DF
equals these three columns or four
columns plus our answer is one of those
so I always think of it as three columns
plus one but it is four columns and then
for the next step we want to make sure
that data is in the right format so
again I'm going to resign the DF and
we're going to mutate the data
and that means we're going to take each
one of these columns and we're gonna let
it know what kind of data that is
so first one is I'm going to put the
database in or the data frame in there
DF and then we want to go ahead and do
survived equals a factor of survived so
this is a yes/no it's letting us know
that this is a 0 or a 1 on here
and then for the class and the age those
are as numeric
there's other ways to process class as
it is a very restricted number on there
but for this we're just going to do it
as a numeric value
same thing with age and you see we
didn't do anything with sex we're just
gonna leave that as male or female and
that's fine for this because it'll pick
up on that when we run the decision tree
and we'll do our ctrl enter so now I've
assigned the new DF and you can see it
comes down below as we run it on there
so this is now loaded and DF now is a
mutated data frame that we started with
and we've set it up with our specific
calls we want to work with in this case
survived class sex and age and we've
formatted three of those columns to a
new setup so one of them is factor
that's what we used for survive so it's
knows it's a 0 and 1 and then we
switched class and age to make sure that
knows that those are numeric values now
that we have our data formatted we need
to go ahead and split the data into a
training and testing data set and by now
if you've done any of our other machine
learning tutorials you know this is
standard you need to have your data that
we trained it with and then you got to
make sure it works on data that it
hasn't trained on so we'll go ahead and
do the splitting let's take a look and
see what that looks like and when you're
dealing with splitting the data we're
doing a little randomness so we'll just
go ahead and set the seed to 1 2 3 you
can set that to whatever number you want
that's just setting the random variable
seed we'll go ahead and hit enter on
there and to do this we're gonna create
sample we go equals sample dot split so
we're splitting up the data this is
actually creating a whole new column
trues and falses it's all stored in
sample one our data frame we use a
dollar sign to denote that we're gonna
be working with one of the different
columns nice thing you can do in our and
actually shows my survived so DF
survived
then our split ratio split ratio I want
to add a period in there which doesn't
have our split ratio is going to be
equal to and we'll do Oh point seven out
so we're going to take 70% of the data
of those that have survived and we're
going to just randomly select which one
of those we're going to use for training
and which one we're going to use for
testing it out later and we'll hit our
enter and load that sample in there
and then we'll go ahead and create our
train in our test data set so I'm gonna
set train equal to this is what kind of
gets interesting because we're gonna do
subset
and then we're going to do a subset of
our DF where sample and then we're going
to use equals since this is a logic
gates wherever it's at sample equal to
true we're gonna use that line in DF and
this is of course R so it's all
capitalized for true so here's our trade
data frame we're creating so when I
execute this and it shows up down below
it goes up and says hey this sample
created a whole bunch of throughs and
false and we're going to take those
trues and falses and wherever we've
created a true which is 70% of the data
randomly selected so we're going to
train the data with and then we need our
test set and that's a subset just the
same thing we just did we need our data
frame and this is where the sample
equals false and again when I hit
control enter it goes down this line of
code and it runs it down here in our
terminal window so now we've nicely
split our data up we have our training
data set and our test data set and this
is of course where we get to the point
of what we're actually trying to do
which is create our decision tree and
we're gonna do that by training the
decision tree as a classifier this
always gets me he spent all this work
sorting through the data reformatting it
in this case mutating it and filtering
it on creating a train set and a test
set so we're gonna go ahead and create
our tree we're gonna assign to it the
are part that's the module we imported
and for the are part we need to go ahead
and do what's called is survived and
this is kind of a little complicated to
look at so let's just take a quick look
at this and I'm going to go backward on
it the first part is we're importing the
data so data equals train and then we
want to knows who survived so the first
part we put in here is the call and
we're looking for is survived and you'll
see that we have out of the squiggly
mark in the period because we're looking
just for this prediction we just want to
know who survived on these boats
for programming our decision tree and
I'll go ahead and hit ctrl enter and
we've now created the tree that tree
with all those values is now in there
and if you remember from before we've
taken from when we did the closet full
of clutter we've done the same thing
where we have our entropy and that one
line computes the entropy and the
increase in information and it brings
the entropy down to zero so it's the
same thing but instead applying it here
as we did visually to the closet it's
now applied it to the data on the ship
it's now looked at the survival of zero
or one based on female male what age
they are
we're the best split of the ages and
what class they ran because here we have
first class if we go down there I think
there's third third second so I guess
it's class one two and three but you see
that's how it split it up says use these
different variables to minimize the
entropy and maximize the information
gained and that's all done in that one
line of code boy we worked on all that
theory and each computer does it for
your in one line of code it's important
to understand the theory behind it so
you know what's happening because as
they make changes to these or if you had
special settings on it you have to know
what they're doing but in this case you
can see that we once we get a format it
the computer does all the heavy lifting
for us and it never ceases to amaze me
just how advanced machine learning has
become these days and how easy it is for
people to get into it and learn the
basic setups and be able to compute your
different machine learning models
once we've computed our decision tree
and we built it on there we want to go
ahead and start doing predictions with
it and what are we going to predict well
you remember that we created our data
with the training tests so we have our
training data which we program the tree
for now we want to see what it does with
the test data so let's see what that
looks like and we can wrap that into
tree dot survived predicted we'll assign
that to our prediction
this is nice because we have the command
predict from one of the modules the are
part module that we brought in
I can simply put in here that we're
gonna use the tree we have our test data
and type this happens to be
classification or class and this would
also be if you were to distribute this
tree you could save the tree and send it
someplace else to be used on new data
this would be the command line you would
use to predict on here predict you have
your tree saved you know whatever data
you're putting through and you let it
know it's doing a classification on the
tree and we'll go ahead and run that so
now that's loaded up and now that we've
gone through we've trained our tree we
run a prediction on our test data
remember the tree had never seen the
test data till now
so we've already built the tree we're
just testing it out and to do that we're
going to use a confusion matrix for
evaluating the model and let's see what
that looks like and that is simply
confusion matrix so once we have the
confusion matrix which came in from our
carrot we need to compare the two
different pieces of data and the first
one's going to be the value we generated
up here we have tree dot survived
predict it so I'm just going to copy
that and paste it down here and then the
second one is the tree we're comparing
that to as he survived there's not the
tree it's easy to get confused sometimes
when you're moving these things around
we're going to compare it to test the
test group of data specifically the
survived column and let's go ahead and
run this and see what that looks like
and so let's go ahead and scroll up a
little bit here to where it first
executed the confusion matrix and the
most important part of this is that we
have our prediction and our reference
and so zero means they didn't survive
one means they survived
we had our prediction on here versus the
actual and that's what these two columns
mean and so when you read this little
chart we have zero zero so both the
prediction and the actual reference
said agreed on 218 values for people who
did not survive little grim there for
daytime ever I talking this is morbid
Teta talking about death rates of people
on boats it says that they both agreed
on 93 so 93 of them where we predicted
the value that they would survive and
the reference came up the same likewise
the predicted were predicted 1 and the
reference said no these people didn't
survive well our prediction got 25 wrong
and where it says they didn't survive
and they actually did I got 57 wrong and
we can come on down with the confusion
matrix and we can look at the accuracy
comes up with the 0.79 1/3 or 95% CI so
you're looking at pretty high accuracy
information ratio p-value when you're in
statistics the p-value is one of the
things we look at remember that there
are certain values if it's over 0.95
it's considered a highly valuable
variable 0.5 means maybe anything less
than that means it's probably not
connected you have to look up the
p-value a little bit more on that then
they just have more information down
here which you can go through and
but you can go through but the Bourdon
part is that we have a very high
accuracy that's what we're looking at
this is a very accurate model and again
always remember the domain you're
working with certainly this is an
example and this is a good little piece
of data you can play with but if I was a
betting money my accuracy came up as 79%
or over 95% CI I'd be like yes let's bet
on that that's a good bet but if I was
bidding on a life-or-death situation I
might kind of rethink that a little bit
if that is if it's gonna affect my life
that way you can also look at this as if
you're trying to figure out where the
boats go in this particular example and
where to put the lifeboats that's
actually pretty good be able to say hey
we can increase the chances of people
surviving this accident by putting the
lifeboats in the appropriate places and
then this is always fun let's visualize
the decision tree one of the cool things
you can do inside of our real easily and
if you remember one of the modules we
brought in has a are part plot we're
gonna take that and we're gonna dump
that into the PRP for the tree and let's
go ahead and hit enter and this is fun
let me move this over so you get a nice
view you can see how it actually split
it up and let me just rerun that again
no they expanded the right you'll see
right here where the one of the biggest
splits was whether the person was male
or female I didn't know that was
probably one of the biggest breaks as
far as lowering the entropy and
increasing the information gate and then
once you know sex is male it came down
here and it said you're not gonna
survive I guess the men were throwing
themselves overboard on the boat I don't
know maybe they're being very gallant
and letting the woman and children
survive which is what I hope that means
so once you know that it's not a male
and it's a female passenger if you were
in class 3 or above you had a high
chance of surviving if you were less in
class 3 your class 1 or 2 then it was
based on age and so you can see where
age was greater than 19 mister anybody
over 19 had a high chance of surviving
and then if they were or less than 19
I'm sorry if the age was a little
confusing on that one but if the age was
one side of 19 they probably survived if
not that it said hey if your age is
less than 60 you proudly survived and if
not people who are older probably didn't
make it out of the boat in time so
elderly have a much higher risk which
you would expect you'd expect that to be
the case that elderly would have a hard
time getting off into the lifeboats and
they would probably step aside for the
younger generation I know I would you
know so it might be more of a social
norm statistic as opposed to a survival
rate let's go and put this back on over
here and see what else we can do with
this data you know if you're working
with the shareholders it's good to have
a lot of tools as far as how to display
you know they'll want to see this number
here where you say hey this is what the
confusion matrix looks like and we got a
point seven nine accuracy that would be
like the number one thing you talk to
the shareholders about other data
scientists care about the p-value and
the information rate and information
like that but this is really the core
right here this is how much data it also
shows them how much data was looked at
so you have a you can actually just add
these numbers together and you can see
how many different people were in the
this particular dataset I mean lines in
the data set but we go ahead and
visualize the 2d decision boundaries so
let's take a look at that that's kind of
fun it's a little bit more complicated
so I'm not going to go into it in too
much detail today
now the guys in the back put this code
together for me which is great so I'm
just gonna paste that in it's like I
said we're not gonna go into it into too
much detail I'm going to just show you
that there's some other ways to display
the data is not just this nice little
tree over here which gives us a little
bit more maybe view of what's going on
as you dig deeper into data that becomes
very important it might not be something
so simple where you can look at in this
case one two three four nodes so they
have four major nodes that they split
the data and so we're looking at this
we're going to go ahead and create a set
test equal to test comma C two for one
we're just assigning color column to go
with the data okay that's what that is
and then we're going to take set and
have it equal to test and we'll do X one
and we're going to set that equal to
minimum set of one minus one max set of
one plus one
by equal 0.01 they had to play with
these numbers a little bit to get this
to look right so we're creating a
sequence on here from our the set we
created so our test set and then x2 is
also creating a sequence based on
different values and then we're going to
put that all into a grid so let's go
ahead and run that through all the way
down to the grid and they'll make a
little more sense when we add the column
names to the grid okay so we'll Center
test will create our x1 sequence and our
x2 sequence remember a sequence is just
like in this case starting with 0.1 it's
like the point o1 0.02 0.03 0.04 so
we're going to create a grid with all
these values separated by 0.01 so that's
all we're doing right now let's go ahead
and set that up
there's our grid and then we want to
ahead and create some column names and
for our grid set we're gonna have our c
class and age so we're just doing the
class and the age on here remember we
did sex also before so it's just class
and age on this chart that we're pulling
out and we're gonna create a Y grit and
the y grid is going to equal tree
survived predict it okay so here's our y
grid and our predicted values on there
now we're actually going to do something
we're gonna plot and we're gonna plot
the y grid oops hold on we see we're
sitting here and let me go ahead and
just run the plot it's got to be the
there we go so let's take a look at this
and see we can make a little sense of
this code and what's going on here
because a couple of things going on what
we've done is we've plotted a decision
tree classification data set we've done
our plot and we have our set
so our sets equal to our test data and
then we have our main we went ahead and
give it a name decision tree and then we
have our X lab and our x limit and we've
set those up as class with our while AB
equals age and our x limit equals range
x1 comma Y limit equals range of x2 and
when you look over here you can see that
we have age on the left and class on the
bottom and so based on age and class and
so once you put in this nice set graph
here we want to go ahead and add our
contours and our points so let's go
ahead and run that and I'm gonna run all
three of these so we can see all the
colors come in on the graph and this is
actually going to take a little bit
because remember you can make it go a
little faster by changing a couple of
the notes up here well we did point o1
from the min to max by changing that to
0.1 or other values you can actually run
a little quicker and we're gonna create
a nice little decision tree
classification test set just to see what
that looks like and how that data
displays now that was taking so long to
run with 0.01 I went ahead and just did
a point 1 so instead of filling the
whole page with different colors for a
really pretty view now I just have these
different colored lines coming across it
gives us another model that we can show
for whoever you're working with in this
case your shareholders of the company or
the individuals here posting to the web
for and you can see where we have the
green and the red and we've set those up
to identify from the decision who's
gonna make it and who's not based on age
in class now my favorite one on this and
I'm gonna go back and just highlight
this really quick was let me just rerun
that go back to PRP tree where we just
play the tree and that's where we split
it in part because this information
gives us some keys that we can then use
in other models
so it's good to know that sometimes
which are taking comes out and maybe you
create a bucket for people under
nineteen between 19 and 60 and over 60
and different things like that so you
can actually put people in buckets and a
class age split just a quick note on
there again you know lots of different
things from which you can display the
data and you can see how we use the
decision tree to figure out chances of
somebody surviving based on their class
and their age so let's go ahead and wrap
it up we have a good time here and let's
look at the key takeaways we went over
what is a decision tree of course we had
our faceless vegetable booth guy whose
gut is I guess he's fruit and vegetables
who has his oranges and carrots and
broccoli which he split up in his
different groups then we went over the
problem solved using decision tree where
we discuss both classification and
regression because you can also do
regression models we went over terms to
know very important to remember entropy
or how chaotic the system is we
discussed information gain and of course
we covered the nodes including the root
nodes and the leaf nodes and then we
went over how the decision tree works we
would looked at the actual math behind
it and how it computes entropy and how
it keeps splitting it until the entropy
is zero or as low as it can get and
finally we went into our r programming
and we wrote an actual script in our to
use the decision tree for survivors on a
boat and we covered both formatting the
data and setting it to predict the
survivors to train and predict and we
also determine the accuracy of the
prediction and looked at a number of
ways we can display that to share that
information with other people so that's
gonna wrap it up for today thank you for
joining us for more information visit
www.mptv.org/outdoorwisconsin
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here